hello everyone welcome back to PGA chain
design channel this channel is about
sharing rhino3d knowledge to student and
3d model professionals learning various
rhino3d technique today we would like to
talk about is making this pendant that
has some design on the side i would like
to talk about where you can get an idea
for the design and also how do you build
this model are you ready let's get
started
[Music]
before we get starting our model this is
a wonderful website I would like to
share with you is called Staller calm it
is a wholesaler website that you have to
have a wholesale license in order to
purchase from them however that's a lot
of a good information on this website
they are the largest wholesaler in the
United States so if you go into the
product they have all different product
that you can take a look on it
especially if you look at the ring let's
take a look on the ring the good things
that I like is the image is really
really big and then they also most of
the image they will give you a tougher
on side view so if you go into anything
that you like and you can click on any
of them and you can quickly to see they
have the 3/4 view and the front view
already so that helped you to understand
what they look like in certain type of a
design especially when you have certain
type of a twist sometimes it's hard to
know what the side view look like so
this is a really good reference website
for you even though you may not have a
license from them yet but you will love
the website so what I'd like you to do
is go into the website and type it the
full prong pendant design and you will
come up almost a full prom pendant
design but the one I would like you to
take a look on it is something like a
little bit fit a great style and
and a good thing is when you go in you
can kind of enlarge it so if you want to
get a detail you can see all those
really big image there okay so there's a
lot of the design you can kind of
explore it with them like this kind of
squirrel type of a design and also give
you a good idea what is the thickness
possible will look like a lot of my
subscriber you guys are just starting
with a jewelry design and a lot of
things about the casting about a
thickness about what is a end product
should look like this will be an
excellent website for you to explore
okay so let's go back to our right now
and let's take a look what we're going
to do today I'm going to maybe make it
into the darker color so easier for you
to see all right so we are going to do a
four prong design one thing that I would
like to mention right here this is the
prong on the twelve o'clock six o'clock
and three and nine and this is a range
for dependent a lot of time if you are
doing a ring which is that the ring
shank is gonna go with the nine o'clock
to 3 o'clock your prong probably need to
move it like 45 degree what I mean is
the prong won't oriented light this way
and it will most likely be oriented like
45 degrees almost like this way okay so
this is look nicer on the ring because
the prong is not gonna hit something
else and that's very small detail but if
you are in the jewelry design you
probably need to know this so let's go
back to our topic today to make this
pendant alright so for this pendant we
are not gonna making the chain you can
take a look on my other video that
actually show you how to make chain and
how to you know make chain for the
rendering so I'm going to delete this
guy right here and we'll make this later
so I'm going to hide this one as well
that's
just take a look this if you look at
this before you actually start building
all the part we have to look at all
overall you can see that this is if
there's no pattern at all it could be a
cup of looking things so what we like to
do is we will peel the cup just the
shape of it and we will actually make a
UV curve and from there we'll do the
design from there let's start with a
stone for any of the desired size you
want it so let's go to the top view at
the top view I'm going to draw a circle
the first circle will be slightly
smaller this is where the bottom circle
will be the second circle will be almost
the same size of our stone okay and then
I'm looking at here my perspective you
see two circle I'm going to move the
first circle down and we want to move it
Lord and the culet because which is the
tip of the stone on the botton because
we want to make sure that any things
that we are working on after we set the
stone the cue light which is this point
right here on my right view it won't
stick it out so it won't scratch any of
your skin okay so I'm going to make this
slightly smaller and then I'm going to
creating a curve it's going to snapping
from this point to this point to
creating the surface I'm going to go to
the surface you have sweep too and go to
rail one rail two and cross-section you
can make them puffy you're almost
straight it's really personal preference
okay so with this we are going to create
a UV curve you can go to curve curve
from the object and then you have create
UV curves then that's snapping on this
surface and hit enter then you will come
up this box right here this box mean if
that surface it's completely flattened
out they
since the area is going to be okay so I
need to have four prong and notice that
the seam is on the 12 o'clock corner so
which means right here on the left side
this is well be the seam so left to the
right those will be the same over there
okay so I would like to do is to
breaking this fall curve into like four
small curve and then on the top in the
bottom I'm going to be typing divided
and I want to divide it into four
sections so that's also tell me where
the prong location will be so easily I'm
going to put a curve from the point a
point so that helped me to divided this
curve into four equal sections and then
so that's where the prong is going to be
and then we want to design within this
area okay so let's take a look what the
prong will look like with this is about
seven millimeters I would like to set my
prong it's about one point two
millimeter so I'm going to my
rectangular and actually I like to use a
conic corner and I have explained this
in other video if you're interesting why
do I like it you can check on those
video so let's go to the front view and
then I'm going to type it one point two
that's for the length and the other
length is called also going to be one
point two and I'm just kind of moving
with my mouse to see what is the shape
looked like okay so this is where the
area is going to have a prong and I'm
going to just have this one and then
copy another one up here and the reason
I want to get it longer is because I
need to have a prong longer so my
jeweler can able to set it then I will
have the command is called loft and I
go from here to there he entered so then
you have the prong and that's go ahead
and cap it so now it is solid okay so we
have one there all we need to do now is
making a bunch of a copy and I wanna
snapping into the end point let's go
take a look on the perspective and
snapping to the end point of each of
them so we know that we are designed
within this area okay so now let's go to
the top and let's do our design so our
first design it's going to be some sort
of a shape I would like to actually put
the one in the middle so what I like to
do is I'm going to go to the perspective
view and then using the split comment
and pick up this one and then we want to
split with this point this point at this
point so we kind of split them into four
equal sections so that way we can
snapping into the middle okay let's go
back to the top view and then we can do
our design right here so the first one I
can snapping into the middle and I kind
of need to know like how high they are
going to be the line right here on the
top if you look back to our original one
is almost just a little bit under the
girdle right so I don't want my design
over or reach the girdle actually I want
to be just a little bit lower than the
girdle so I think that it's a good
position right there from there I'm
going to use my curve and snapping into
the endpoint and kind of design some
sort of leaf looking things something
like this okay and I'm going to Miro
that to the other side all right so
that's my first leaf and it's really up
to you how you like them I actually like
them a little
fad and so that will come up the better
casting quality and I'm going to use my
ellipse tool on the second one with the
diameter and I'm going snapping into the
quadrant - Kaza and you want to go into
the front view to do it kind of using
the prong to give me a good idea of how
thick they should look like
alright so now this is my one of the
profile I'm going to make another
profile with the same comment going from
here to here and again we won't go to
the front view and we want to go
something it's a little bit thin there
to start with
okay so now what we can do sweep -
you're going to go to the surface and
you go to sleep - rail rail one Realty
you're gonna go from here to here now
very important things as you need to go
to this point by clicking the point on
the top I'm going to show you what
happened if you don't do it it will just
give you half of it right and then you
probably need to do one more time here
here and go from here to the point and
it looked like this not much different
because you can just join this one back
but in fact you got this is a two
surface joined together now you have a
poly surface what is the disadvantage is
you can turn on the control point on the
poly surface so I want to turn it on it
will say D cannot turn on the point for
poly surface okay so I'm going to go
back one step
that's do it one more time sweep to rail
one rail to going here to here and then
make sure do you click to the point okay
and now you look at this no seem right
in the middle and what it does is if we
need to do additional editing and then
we can turn on a control point that way
we can turn it on so this is really
important step a lot of people just you
know don't think this is
not much different but it does make a
huge difference okay so we want to cap
it so now we have that first one okay
the the one on the side I do like to do
something more like this drawing a curve
roughly here and I want to coming up a
little bit and do a little bit more
curve or something like this all right
and then you can simply pipe it or you
can use any of the profile that you
wanted to do I'm going to creating the
profile and again use the colony corner
and with the center so let's take a look
snapping into the end point of this
curve and then we want to go to the
front view and to holding the shift'
kind of eyeball like the size that you
like and then click on it so you will
have this curve right there and let's go
ahead and sweep it and see what does it
look like I'm going to use this sweep
one rail I'm gonna click on this profile
and then you have something like this
okay the one that we have and look like
it is kind of inside of the shape and I
do like it to come up a little bit more
so I may wanted to have this one going a
little bit and maybe you want to
increasing the thickness on this one
so that way you will come up a little
bit more and I do not like you know the
dis showing like little piece showing on
the right side of the sweep we just have
so I may want to just make it a little
bit skinnier okay and you can do any of
the editing at this point before you do
anything make sure you cap this one so
that way they look nicer
it's ready to bowling okay you can do
any editing on this one for example
giving more of the dimension what you
can do is to click on this one and I
want to use the pen tool and kind of
bending this one just come out a little
bit like this so it giving a little bit
more dimension on it okay and so we have
that one let me get a slightly thicker
and also you can take a render view to
see how they look all right so you have
something like this you can keep
tweaking until you know the one you like
I'm just gonna save our time here to
finish this design going to Miro make
sure you snapping into the midpoint now
we have a lot of things to snap here and
then so I have that over there okay and
then I'm going to pick up all the
surface and that's go ahead copy from
the midpoint of the curve and then we
want to copy to all of my point right
here my point there and me point there
okay so now we have all the copy one
more things I would like to do is I'm
gonna pick up all my prong and then and
make sure that they are tilted outside a
little bit so that way you know it will
spread it out instead of a go straight
go straight were cutting into my stone
too much before I actually flow it back
I will also like to make Phillip ages
all the things on the top so I'm going
to try point two millimeter okay so they
come out really good okay alright so now
it's the time to get a flow back to the
top
we need to creating a surface snapping
into this end point to the end point and
that gives us a good reference for where
they are okay and let's go to the
perspective
before we flow it back we want to make
sure we click on Rico history and then
we want to go to the transform and you
have the flow along the surface you want
to pick up everything there and I'm
going to try one of the corner I say
this corner and I'm gonna come back here
and click on this corner
alright so one more things here I
usually don't like the one on the seam
because it may not be correct but this
one look alright okay so we don't no
longer need this surface and I want to
call out my curve right there and then
we just need to pipe it or you can make
another profile to fit the profile most
of the profile you have we just need to
have some sort of support underneath it
next things we need to do is to pale the
barrel is quite simple I'm gonna
creating an arc like this and then close
to where the middle I just gonna put
attack right there okay so this tag is
going to help us to have better curve it
will flow better and I'm going to use
the blend tool to blame from this point
at that point okay so we have really
smooth plane over there and let me trim
or split by the point where is the
quadrant is right so that's did it that
one not about it okay so now if I am
going to move this out a little bit so
easier for you to see what we'd like to
do is we want to creating the profile so
in this case I have this profile that's
going to be somewhere like
this a little bit thinner than the prong
and then we are going to have another
profile looking at the top view again
starting from the center and this one
I'd like to be a little bit thicker
I don't want to overpowering my pendant
so we'll have something like this okay
and let's go ahead to do the radius
first so that's fitted the OD corner
this one I wanted to have 0.5 millimeter
that's too big let's say we wanted to do
point 3 millimeter and this one already
is gonna be really small let's try
pointing one and see how you work it it
looks alright okay so we're gonna use
the sweep one rail going from here to
here and then so we'll take a look and
then oh that's a very good example here
the reason it has almost like a twisting
surface there is because the I think
move the arrow so sometimes you just
cannot get lazy thinking that will pass
right now it's really honest okay so
let's move all of them back to the
midpoint at the same time alright so now
you see is much nicer alright so we have
that one all we need to do is to me roll
to the other side so let's go ahead to
me roll this one back to here all right
now if you go ahead want to bowling this
because it has an intersection you might
encounter some problems so my trick is
going to be using the cap tool kept
coming and you're gonna cap this one and
kept this one individually so they both
become solid then you want to bullying
join them okay so that way you want
creating the problem folder bowling and
then we want to move it in a little bit
make sure you have a good counter
that way you will have a good casting
okay and also little things here this
one I usually like to do and that's
forgery design specific purpose I always
like to move this one lease align with
the bottom of my setting the reason is
that way it will hang it correctly it
will lay flat to your customers chest
okay so those are the little trick about
the jewelry design I hope you enjoy the
video and please like and comment and
share my video that's really important
for me because that's the only way I can
continue making free video for you thank
you for watching I'll see you next
Monday